this is from the daily wire it says
stranger things Star Caleb McLaughlin
told a group over the weekend that some
fans of the show are racist because they
wouldn't take pictures with him during
the first season
in a video that surfaced on Twitter on
Sunday the 20 year old actor said at the
heroes Comic-Con Belgium that he dealt
with racism early in his career after
being the only black kid on the series
McLaughlin said it definitely took a
toll on me as a younger kid my very
first Comic-Con some people didn't stand
in my line because I was black
some people told me like oh I didn't
want to be in line because you were mean
to 11. even now some people don't follow
me or don't support me because I'm black
he also shared that sometimes overseas
you'll feel the racism the bigotry
uh sometimes it's hard to talk about and
for people to understand but when I was
younger it definitely affected me a lot
but there's more so the evidence that he
was a victim of racism is that when he
went to Comic-Con
um there were more there weren't as many
people in his line as in other lines and
he knows it's because of racism
he continues um
let's see
he also says at another point I'm trying
to find the exact quote here but he also
talks about how uh he has fewer
Instagram followers than than some of
his co-stars
oh he says why do I have the least
amount of followers I'm on the same show
as everybody from season one my parents
had to be like it's the sad truth but
it's because you're the black child on
the show
so he has 15 million followers on
Instagram
is 15 million followers on Instagram
with it which is less than some people
on the show but more than others and
according to him he said to his parents
hey Mom and Dad I only have 15 million
Instagram followers and his parents said
to him yeah it's because you're black
it's you're a victim of racism that's
what it is
if you weren't black then you'd have you
know you have 30 million followers
this is
uh
Hollywood actors they just they
absolutely love accusing their own fans
of racism this is what they love to do
more than anything and it is seriously
every week now there's another one of
these
and on top of that it also appears that
they're all mind readers
so when he's at Comic-Con and there are
fewer and he looks over at one line and
there's a few more people in it and he
can look and he can read all their minds
and tell that the reason they're not in
his line is that they hate black people
makes a lot of sense
and I'll do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]